about our rights
and our security our safety for years
rohingya leader muhabillah regularly
received death threats and predicted he
had been killed like many other rohingya
refugees mohammed qasim says he feels
devastated for years now we've been
watching and following
he was a gem to us and has done so much
for us but we couldn't save him he took
our case to the global community to seek
justice for us
came to prominence when he was chosen to
represent his community on a visit to
meet then u.s president donald trump at
the white house and attend a u.n human
rights council session in geneva in 2019
this is the place where rohingya
community leader muhibullah was shot
dead wednesday night there's an uneasy
calm prevailing in the camp and heavy
presence of security rohingya refugees
are worried and anxious to find out who
is behind the killing
a funeral was held for muhibullah inside
the camp among those there his wife and
eight children
he left me with so much responsibility i
am devastated
how can i manage the family now it's a
difficult road ahead i am scared to live
here now we need security he is dead now
only allah can give us justice
police say the mother was well planned
all police units are involved in
resolving this case and finding the
motive behind it we got some important
information today and detained a suspect
hopefully we will resolve this case soon
in recent months the office of the
refugee relief and repatriation
commissioner has severely restricted
media access to the cox's bazar refugee
camp making it difficult to gather news
but it's clear many refugees feel
fearful and angry
we're very worried about his killing he
was a leader in the community he pleaded
our cause to the world
many who did not want to be identified
on camera told al jazeera that the
murder is the latest example of a fight
for power between armed gangs inside the
world's largest refugee camp chanwi
choudhary al-jazeera kutupalong cox's
bazar